المرشح بايدن الذي سمعته هناك قال
إنه سيحاسب المملكة العربية السعودية
الآن بعد أن أصبح رئيسًا ولم يفرض أي
حظر على السفر ولا تجميد للأصول ولا تهم جنائية
، والأهم من ذلك أنه لا توجد عقوبات
مباشرة على ولي العهد نفسه ،
لماذا لم يكن حسنًا أولاً من
اليوم الأول للإدارة
لقد كنا واضحين تمامًا على كل
المستويات بدءًا من الرئيس وما بعده ،
وسنقوم بإعادة ضبط هذه
العلاقة وطي صفحة
السنوات الأربع
الماضية وهذا يعني إنهاء دعمنا
للحرب في اليمن وبذل المزيد لمعالجة
الأزمة
الإنسانية وضمان  أننا
نحاسب أفعال انتهاكات حقوق الإنسان
لهذه الحكومة بالقول والفعل ،
فإن إصدار هذا التقرير الذي تم
تأجيله على مدى السنوات الأربع الماضية
هو جزء من ذلك لتوضيح ذلك
للجمهور ولكننا اتخذنا أيضًا  عدد من الخطوات من
خلال وزارة الخزانة من خلال
وزارة الخارجية
لمعاقبة نائب رئيس المخابرات
لمعاقبة الثوري
القوات في المملكة العربية السعودية ولتوضيح
أننا لن ندع هذا يحدث مرة
أخرى ، وهذه رسالة من الواضح أننا
أرسلناها خلال الأيام القليلة الماضية ، حسنًا ،
لكنك تتحدث
عن الأشخاص الذين يخضعون لولي
العهد وهم  يتم معاقبتهم ،
لذا لا يتم معاقبتهم مثل معاقبة
القاتل وليس رئيس الغوغاء الذي
وضع الضربة
بشكل جيد أولاً تاريخيًا وحتى في
التاريخ
الحديث لم يتم
فرض عقوبات على قادة الدول الأجنبية.
الحكومات التي لدينا
علاقات دبلوماسية وحتى عندما
لا توجد لدينا علاقات دبلوماسية
ونعتقد أن هناك طرقًا أكثر
فاعلية للتأكد من عدم حدوث ذلك مرة
أخرى وللتمكن أيضًا من ترك مساحة
للعمل مع السعوديين في المناطق التي
هناك اتفاق متبادل حيث توجد
مصلحة وطنية للولايات المتحدة
وهذا ما تبدو عليه الدبلوماسية وهذا
هو شكل المشاركة العالمية
المعقدة ونحن  لم يخفِ أي سر وكان
واضحًا أننا سنحملهم المسؤولية
وعلى المسرح العالمي وفي
الإجراءات المباشرة ، نعم
أسمعك ولكن أقول إنك تحمّلهم المسؤولية ولا
يبدو الأمر كذلك عندما يتعلق الأمر
بالمفهوم  من
العدالة والسؤال هو هل تشعر أن
العدالة قد تحققت حقًا عندما
يتعلق الأمر على وجه التحديد بولي العهد ودوره
في القتل الوحشي للصحفي
لأن الصحفي
كان يعمل على قصص كانت
تتحدىه
جيدًا فهذه جريمة مروعة و
قال الرئيس
بنفسه إنني سأكرر هنا اليوم أن
أحد أسباب قيام وزارة الخارجية
بوضع ما نسميه قاعدة خاشقجي هذه
هو أننا نعتقد أن أي شخص
يهدد الصحفيين ويهدد المعارضين
يجب أن يحاسب ويجب ألا "
يجب أن يكون
قد تم إلغاء تأشيرات السفر الخاصة بهم ، فهذه
مشكلة عالمية وقد اتخذنا
إجراء يوم الجمعة
في نفس الوقت الذي تحتاج فيه دانا إلى أن تكون
نظيفة  نظرًا لأن علاقتنا مع المملكة
العربية السعودية
هي علاقة من
مصلحة الولايات المتحدة الحفاظ عليها بينما
لا يزال واضحًا أنه سيتم
إعادة ضبطها ، سنحاسبهم
على انتهاكات حقوق الإنسان
وسنتخذ إجراءات بما في ذلك  الإجراءات
التي أعلنتها وزارة الخارجية
ووزارة الخزانة يوم الجمعة